to me he started I think 48 games in his
collegiate career so the development I
don't know what was really left I mean I
think he kind of arrived as a ready-made
player so the fact that he wasn't
playing early I don't know I feel like
it's almost like you're driving around
an amusement park like on a loop and go
and that's a great amusement park like
just get off the freeway and go go to
the amusement park it's right there you
keep circling around I know that's you
point out when he's the one who was
denying the talent from starting but
look like the bottom line is he got in
because the Jets helped release the it
that's what they do
yep um so we'll get to that in a second
in turn is that a hashtag yeah release
the hashtag it lets gets us started your
assessment of what you saw from Baker
Mayfield last night it was it was how
you come away with any other takeaway
that was outstanding I mean to me the
biggest thing no fear no hesitation
trusted his eyes and got the ball out
what's working in the middle of the
field
you saw anticipation you saw velocity
you saw accuracy and the numbers could
have been even better I mean when you
look at some of the drop passes namely
the one to Callaway deep down the field
and more than anything else rich I it
sounds hokey but you could just you
could feel it you could feel the energy
in the stadium you could feel the energy
with his teammates it just he kind of he
kind of brought everybody up and that
was a lot of the things that were said
about him at Oklahoma you saw a lot of
those things come out last night so how
sustainable for mm he's got he's got
things that that are gonna sustain I
mean when you can throw the ball that
accurately when you show that type of
poise and and that kind of no flinch
mentality I think that's something
that's gonna that's gonna maintain
you're gonna see that throughout the
year now he's gonna have slip-ups like
any rookie would he's gonna see
coverages that he doesn't recognize he's
gonna make some mistakes he's good you
saw a sack force fumble last night
you're gonna see some of that was it
dropped interception zone you're gonna
see you're gonna see some some bumps in
the road but to me you've you've got
your guy at least it's it's one game but
right now small sample size I'd man I'd
be feeling great if your Cleveland okay
and so what about darn 'old what do you
say fine okay I crack up at this I mean
you mentioned it three games in what 10
11 days short week go on the road you
play against Greg Williams a defense
that's loaded with talent I'm I said
before the year I think miles Garrett
will be the
offensive player of the year I'm not
backing off that from what we've seen we
could he's a freaking I thought early on
in that game he hit Donald and Donald
got up a little bit gimpy and I thought
from that moment on the Jets kind of
made a decision like we're gonna run the
football and we're gonna get it out
quick we're not gonna subject our young
quarterback to a beating back there and
so everybody's killing him always not
throwing the ball down the field and
like he's not gonna have time to throw
the ball down the field they did what
they had to do so evaluate I guess the
idea of Mayfield versus darn 'old that
we're gonna be seeing throughout the
entire day in jumps of taking just I
guess put a button on that subject and
in itself what we saw last night from
two rookie quarterbacks under the lights
how sustainable are they do the both
teams have their guys beyond 2018
absolutely I mean I've said when we were
going through this draft process I
thought this was an outstanding classic
we talked about a year ahead of time and
then as every year we start picking
these guys apart but I tried to stay
true to and say look I think these guys
are franchise quarterbacks whenever we
see Josh Rose and you're gonna see it
from him as well now Josh Allen's a
little bit more of a longer term play
but Sam darn 'old
the that was impressive what we saw week
one for Baker may feel was impressive
and last week I mean Donnell I think
threw for 330 plus against the Dolphins
defense that's not bad I mean he is he
is going to be fine both these teams are
in good shape the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience